it's a fool a Capcom exclusive that's
what's up man I want to talk to you man
about like Houston hip-hop I feel like I
feel like it's kind of on its way back
around of course there was a huge surge
with everybody Paul ball Mike Jones
everybody yeah and then I feel like it
kind of like got dry for a little bit it
was like the buzz coming out of Houston
and now you know everybody's cut out to
screw every I mean you got ASAP Rocky
who's heavily influenced by heavily
influenced by H Town Car Co bangs is
doing this thing and Travis Scott how do
you feel
as far as Houston and the scene in
Houston do you feel like these young
dudes are representing right I mean I
cuz I feel like each one of you guys you
know of course that class that you came
out of like everybody sold a shitload of
records everybody you know had it for
the most part everyone had a cohesive
sound and I feel like these new dudes
everyone's kind of doing their own thing
out of houston it feels it feels a
little different yeah it is a little
different Houston and a lot of people
are kind of like in the city that kind
of felt a certain way because they'd be
like you know how all these other dudes
doing this h-town music and we've been
doing it and I hear that the vibe from a
lot of people in city but the one thing
I will say about a lot of these new
people that are on doing this crude
music like they say that by ASAP it
doesn't sound like screw busy to me well
I mean I see what I see I see the
influence just because he screws he
screws some of his lyrics a [__] Drake
early Drake like that further but a
that's my point like if you listen to
the Houston sound right the traditional
original Houston sound it doesn't sound
like what these guys are doing right
here influenced by it so they're putting
a twist on it and I think that's what
makes the mainstream acceptable to the
sound because it's not the same thing
nobody wants to hear the same thing ten
movies later - I just on it so like you
were one of the original
h-town dudes who really kind of like I
want to say you you kind of did one of
different lands that's why
you have to understand I understand that
people are putting the twist on it
because that's what's making it fresh
again it's re-energizing the sound you
know the mean that there's nobody riding
around right now in California right now
with a fully screwed CD like Alma calm
down Alma blah and that's what we used
to do right right now everybody's taking
the screwed sound and put a little twist
on it and you know you know I have stuff
that screwed and it's got like EDM under
it or is that dubstep under it like this
is a different twist on screwed music so
that's why it's like refreshing it's
energizing it you know so I can
understand why a lot of these white kids
out here they're buying this music can
get excited about this again doesn't
mean and then the problem is that some
people like oh they don't understand
where it comes from like we don't
control the world I don't control the
world I don't know what people think
when they hear it I can't like be mad at
that type of stuff you know I get on my
Twitter stream all day fends like cam
you created this sound they need to pay
homage like I don't even think like that
right you know um you you I feel like
when it comes to Chamillionaire man like
like you like we were talking earlier
you're kind of like ahead of your time
because I remember the online work used
to put in man like was crazy I remember
always you know seeing [__] on your
myspace contest you would do a fan stuff
like that like today do you find it a
little bit harder to win over some of
these young kids man because I feel like
the young kids their attention span is
so small because there's so much music
to digest like yeah it's like non-stop
free mixtapes online like every day it's
like you need to be an artist
I like the way you talk man you know but
you know honestly um yeah I mean every
rapper feels a certain you know bit of
that and and especially when it comes to
like people what I get the most is like
it's not like people don't think you
dope it's like you just don't drop
enough stuff you got to keep up with
everybody dropping all these videos they
ain't got to do the viral video a lot of
stuff I do is like it's not because I
can't you know mean like I people think
your career starts ending and then you
get to a point where you can't do it
it's because there's certain things I
see people work for people I just choose
not to do like I think I used to get him
a car a drive from Houston to Cleveland
drop off CDs I just at this point in my
life I choose not to do that
so if that works for somebody else
awesome but I don't want to do that you
know and as far as these videos go get a
guy with a 5 B camera put out a bunch of
just videos just to stay on
today there's any one thing I don't want
to do it I'd rather like and then a lot
of people make CDs and put out a bunch
of free CDs mixed age you're in a studio
spend a thousand dollars put out if
that's that your business model that
works you awesome on today I have a
dedicated fan base that buys a lot of
stuff so why wouldn't I sell it some
song and you know that's just the way I
feel I'm gonna operate so you know or
the majors like even like in your cards
anymore to even like look look to like
get another deal or you just comfortable
and honestly when I left Universal I'm a
lawyer at the time you know Oprah's
lawyer you don't come passing a big guy
you know he was like let's go get
another one and I was like no I was like
no I want to look at that time in like
you have like a lot of pool like as far
as alright to this day are still doing
you don't mean like I've talked to a lot
of people enables you know but um the
reason why is because I'm not saying
that labels are bad you know I mean you
just gotta go in there with it with
leverage and it's all it's all about
leverage yeah and it's all the stuff
that I see you know anybody's every day
they sign you know say a new rapper sign
a deal but nobody ever asked what are
you
you know man like to this day that same
rapper might have to do so much it's
just to get what I'm making that even on
the label like I still make if you buy
something today I make fifty percent
every to every day so they still cut me
checks you have to do business on your
the rest of my way and so at that time I
didn't own Universal nothing so I was
thinking man this is the best time to
leave because you know the label system
is designed to make you owe money so now
if they give me in debt then I won't cut
me check so now there are no money let
me get out there the rest of my life you
guys just keep paying me half Volkswagen
calls and once a commercial that caught
me boom I negotiate it I sterile my
chick you know is in it so I I think
from a business mind like that and I
can't say that I wouldn't go do some
kind of situation with a major because
all the stuff that I'm doing if you see
like we're gonna do buy we're shooting
videos we're in Saddam Hussein's palace
shooting videos and all the stuff that
I've never put out because I choose not
to put out though 5d videos I collected
all this greatness and be like when it's
time I'm gonna put it on DVD no it's
gonna it's gonna be I don't want to put
it out in the backyard for just my own
Oreos you see I want the world to see it
but I just I'm gonna have a little bit
more leverage when I show them what I
got you don't feel you man I feel you is
it is it that's one thing I feel like
it's it seems like it's a little the way
the Internet is take
/ hip-hop is just like the way people
consume music it feels like it's a
little harder to stay current and
relevant when you you're competing
against like you said like guys who put
out visuals non-stop it's just you see
there's two different sides of relevancy
I think I think there's a lot of people
that feel like you know I need it sweet
every day I need a post on Facebook
every day I need to be on the blogs
every day just so I could stay relevant
but what happens for three weeks when
you when you run out of steam and then
you don't do nothing no I called again I
think I think see I think I think that
that there's like a difference between
like not being liked per se like a hot
name but you still have like I feel like
you or somebody who no matter what you
still like commanding air carries
respect as an artist as an emcee as all
that stuff and then there's other guys
who like who are just like I don't want
to call out names but you know there's
other rappers that that they lose their
relevance they're not hot and they're
just like like they're like they had
their time but they can what they did
really wasn't respected as much - like
camera I appreciate that but I will say
that depends on who you ask is there are
people that say that about me - I don't
feel that way about it it doesn't like
it doesn't bother me and does it make me
feel that way because I in my heart know
what I'm capable of you know but what I
will say is that I I think all of this
stuff that everybody's doing with all
these shows all the stuff it doesn't
really matter man I think all it boils
down to is making the songs a known hit
what was it everything comes right you
know look at Juicy J I got a show with
him tonight here's no writer and he's a
perfect more example all it is I always
tell everybody like everyone is a hit
record away from being hot again that's
it
he could be Coolio or I mean seriously
yeah so so the test of time for me is
that if I come up with all this great
stuff that I say I got and there's
nothing like that dick then I was wrong
so what are we waiting when it's right
you got the EPO and it's right get it co
the EPS and stuff that I put out it's
just like a placeholder teasers when you
go listen to them you'll see that it's
still dope is still quality the artwork
everything looks dope there's still that
lizard logo you know and I'm still doing
a good amount of sales off of each one
so somebody's like oh well cam dropping
another album it probably went would
they have no idea these independent guys
probably couldn't sell what I sell on my
website like right now as we speak I
think I think I have one of the biggest
are as websites
I really do 5650 Cindy's not this is 50
that's the only one that I think is just
like super big but what score as far as
like you know interaction with fans like
you'll see comments that have like 300
400 comments you're buying everything I
put out how to email this one emailing
them every day
all these responses thousands of dollars
that's all that matters as long as like
you got your fan base and as long as you
know I to me like if I was an artist as
long as I could live comfortably off
doing some I love like making hip hop
that's what I'm doing and that was the
reason why I had that conversation with
my lawyer cuz at the time he was like
what are you gonna do are you gonna get
back in your car and you gonna start
driving to Cleveland and dropping off
mixtapes and I was like nah maybe I'll
go invest in some stuff maybe I got
which I did yeah you night yeah and then
I was like you know maybe I'll go do
this and and I just figured you know the
best way for me to do the music that I
want to do is to go and create it in the
event that I'm done and I'll come back
to the majors and say hey this is what I
got and they don't like it they can
choose not to mess with it but I would
rather do it that way than be in a
session like last time I was in a
session right at the label I walked in I
was a little bit late walked in and
they're like whoa wait can we're not
done yet so I was like oh I have to step
on my own session there's people in
there singers everybody making a song
for me what are you alright when it gets
to the point you're not even telling you
I'm a story that's not what you need to
be so that's not all these young cast us
out here doing it they're making the
music they want to make crit j.cole go
down a line every same I know anything
about about the new format time is
because people they do what they want
they build up their fanbase and then
it's you like you said it's all about
the leverage then they get the leverage
and then you know the labels you know
yeah exactly and I was in there it was
like everybody come for a verse I wanna
you know like I'm a mixtape artist so
you know sometimes people would be like
man I need a verse for this mixtape and
I want to give him 48 bars or whatever
right and then it would be like oh no we
can't clear you because you know it was
just like come on or if they did clear
me they charge like 10 million dollars
for the person clear so I had to do it
for free just so it wouldn't be that
expensive and I just got to the point
where I was like man this is just you
know I think you know we're Samael
artists that you're [__] with man you
lose people you bombuh right oh man um
honestly I don't really listen to
anybody like a lot because I feel like
as an artist you kind of like
subliminally start taking stuff like a
food he puts up that song hustle hard it
becomes a hit you hear it everywhere and
sublimity everybody starts rapping like
them
that same pattern right done something
I've done done I've done about that and
I'm just like man dude didn't realize
did you swag check and isn't it without
even know so I try not so this is people
cuz I don't want to steal from them when
I want to start getting the itch to
start singing that auto-tuning nothing
like that right right so but I find like
greatness in like a little bit of
everything like I like crit I like Jake
oh like dick Shawn I like all the new
cats ASAP I've heard stuff in there that
was cool you don't see them but I can't
say I like listen to everybody like
everyday like I'm not man well hey man
we appreciate you coming through reports
there's a new new album because I was
waiting for venom forever is no longer
venomous poison now poison oak set it up
and it's gonna be ill I don't want to
say too much because every time I say
something I feel like somebody taking my
ideas man you know so I'm not saying too
much now but when it's ready you know
I'm gonna come back up here you already
know there it is Chamillionaire makes
you hit him online what is the website
later boom